right it is time to tap into a higher
version of yourself in an immersive
class taught in an area like no other
and joining us to tell us more is
wellness instructor and vegas icon dre
gardner welcome it is so good to have
you here thank you for having me thank
you for having me well we ought to
experience yoga in a way that is really
kind of iconic at a place that is really
cool tell us about this new experience
you have going on you know area 15 has
been kind enough to open their doors and
really believe in this health and
wellness initiative that i've been
preaching a while in this community and
coming out of kobe you know now more so
never we need a place to heal and to me
there wasn't a better place they have
the most incredible space i've ever got
to do yoga in
and i'm trying to bring everybody
together it's the central part of town
and really it's just you immerse
yourself
you're in it for 70 minutes it's it's
like the senses all of the senses are
being utilized it's just the sight the
sounds and just everything it is truly
immersive and tell us a little bit about
it if someone has never done yoga before
what what can they expect going into
this i teach my classes for all levels
so from beginning to advanced i teach
for all levels so there's always
something for you to do
you're never too young never too old
never too weak never too sick to pick up
a yoga mat just do your best i've taken
your class before and it truly is an
experience i love it i didn't come
dressed for yoga today i didn't know
where to do yoga so i'm gonna do my best
but let's maybe you could show us a
couple of vienna yoga poses yoga poses
arms up over your head
and then nice and slow
just body to the right and hips to the
left oh right
foot three
four two
inhale back up
and now i'm gonna go your way stretch up
and now we're gonna go body left
hips right
breathe
four
three
two
one inhale coming up and we're gonna
cactus our arms and now drop your head
back and push your hips
forward open up your heart smile for
three
for two
and change hands back up
back to your heart center
slight bow your chin
namaste no let's see i love that my
favorite pose is savasana that's the
best one savasana is the best we work
hard to get there that's when you lay
down at the very end and you relax now i
mean you are the pro can you show us
something that's more for the advanced
uh
absolutely
kind of move out of the way
let's see an advanced pose here we can
do a handstand
okay
that is um
that's not something that i will be
doing in the class but that you could do
a handstand
oh my
and then at what point of the class do
you do this
uh
you know at some point everybody tries
to do it i i teach it
so if i can do it she can do it kendall
timmy you ready
come here you're dressed for yoga today
tell us a little bit how people can be a
part of the event it looks absolutely
fantastic
area15.com you can also
check them on instagram or facebook for
tickets
it's an incredible experience we have
one this saturday we have our next two
in april so check the calendars for
those dates and as well we'll push it
into may june and july so look forward
to this health and wellness that we're
bringing to las vegas
at area 15 and uh
be ready to fall in love with yourself
again one of the best yoga teachers in
vegas right here you got to check it out
thank you thank you thank you so much
we're going to send it over to you
kendall dre it's great seeing you he has
a mesmerizing voice too doesn't he he's
one of the best just makes you relax
all right speaking of wellness a lot of
you may be